Here is the graphical representation of the garage door opener.
I've used rectangles in this case, but there are six, six states indicating
the six states we, we listed before. The the arc,
the transition arcs have two two expressions on them.
The first one, the first is the event causing the transition,
if there's then a slash, the second one is the event to take,
that will happen upon that transition occurring. So imagine, for
example we're at the bottom, in the state labeled Door Open Motor Off.
And in this case, there's only one outgoing arc.
The user has pressed the button and, in this case, the motor starts and
it moves into the state where the motor is running downward. The door was open,
it was at the top. Hence, the only place that the door can go is downward.
Similarly, you can walk yourself through the diagram.
The interesting situation involving epsilon transition takes place
if you are in the bottommost state on the right,
labelled Motor Running Down. If, then, the button is pressed, okay,
recall that the first thing that happens is the motor is stopped and
we transition into the Door Partially Closed Motor Off state just above it.
But when we go on, okay, remember the, the safety concern. The door was going
down and we stopped, and we now want to take it up. So there's a transition to
the left in which there is no event causing the transition. Okay? So
immediate transition and what we want to do is start the motor going upward and
end up in the state at the extreme left labeled Motor Running Up